et en direct l'italie pour parler de ce
green pass en direct avec nous matteoli
alberti des journalistes franco italien
bonjour merci d'être avec nous alors ce
green parce qu est ce qu il le dit faire
du pas sony terre qu'on a désormais en
france il ya peu de différence entre la
carte verte
on l'appelle ici en italie mais unia
utiliser un anglicisme donc green face
et c'est l'air française disons que en
ce qui concerne dans des restaurants on
n'a pas besoin de montrer le past and i
terre quand on s'installe à l'extérieur
1 terrasse ni quand on vous prend une
consommation au ban du bar du café
c'est quelque chose que les italiens
font très souvent justement avec les
cafés et les cappuccino à l'heure du
petit déjeuner en revanche si on veut ce
soir à l'intérieur d'un bar ou d'un
restaurant il faut montrer se passe à
lithaire autre chose qui est qu'un
l'italie a été décidée c'est de
permettre aux clients des hôtels de
continuer à pouvoir accéder au restant à
l'intérieur de l'hôtel pendant leurs
vacances sans devoir présenter les
greens passe parce que c'est
pratiquement impossible de contrôler les
clients qui avaient réservé des mondiaux
des vacances de
pendant des semaines et leur passage
dans les lieux de restauration des
hôtels en france en il faut deux doses
ans pour avoir un passé militaire
effectifs en italie vous confirmer qu'il
suffit d'une seule dose ou alors une
fois avoir un schéma vaccinal complet il
faut avoir un schéma vaccinal complet
pour la plupart des comment dire des
lieux où il faut montrer le pass
sanitaires en revanche si encore une
fois on reste à l'extérieur par exemple
on peut avoir seulement un max intime d
avoir réussi seulement l'une de doses et
puis aussi pour il ya en tout cas
quelques quelques incompréhensions pour
les règles qui ont été établies pour les
transports parce que par exemple on ne
devrait présenter le passé ni terre
quand on prend un train par exemple qui
traversent la frontière d'une région à
l'autre
mais par exemple on n'a pas besoin de
présenter le père sanitaires dans les
ferries qui relient la calabre avec la
sicile
donc on ne comprend pas pourquoi
certains réglages ont été en tout cas à
mende et alors que les situations les
circonstances dans lesquelles on
pourrait sait contaminé sont exactement
les mêmes se gagne pas c'est sera imposé
aux enseignants seulement aux
enseignants à tous les adultes qui
travaillent dans les écoles apparemment
c'est tous les adultes et aussi pour
l'instant pour les étudiants
universitaires ont l'instant les lycées
et les collèges sont exemptés mais il ne
peut pas oublier que déjà à l'école
primaire l'italie avait fait le choix de
imposer le masque aux enfants à partir
de 6 ans et que maintenant enfin
j'espère au moins l'entrée en vigueur de
ce green pass pour accès pour arriver en
italie allait présenter un parcours
vaccinale complet ou bien des tests
négatifs aussi pour les enfants à partir
de alors il ya eu les réticences de la
ligue à ce green pass et la population
italien dans son ensemble est ce que
vous la santé plutôt favorable plutôt
hostile à ce fameux pass tout le monde
comme en france se crée en finir avec ce
cauchemar mais les italiens aussi sont
plutôt critique surtout pour l'attitude
enfants utilisant également utilisé par
le gouvernement italien et la
stigmatisation qui a été introduite un
peu comme c'était le cas en france avec
des discours comme celui du porte-parole
du gouvernement gabriel attal ou même du
président de la république emmanuel
macron en italie aussi il ya eu cette
espèce de condescendance vis à vis des
citoyens qui en fait pour la plupart des
cas d'ailleurs sont vaccinés comme
aimait ma principale d'avoir cette
imposition c'était restrictions de la
liberté d'ailleurs il faut aussi dire
que il ya beaucoup des citoyens italiens
qui souhaiteraient se faire vacciner
mais qui ne trouvent pas de rentrer de
goût ou bien il ya des citoyens italiens
qui par exemple réside ou travaille dans
la petite république de samara qui ont
été vaccinés avec le vaccin unique 5 et
qui ne peuvent pas voir reconnu leur
leur parcours vaccinale parce que ce
vaccin n'est pas reconnu à haut niveau 2
les mains matteo et les avertit en tout
cas merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions je rappelle que vous êtes
journaliste franco italien vous étiez en
direct avec nous depuis l'italie mercier